my conclusion is
that wrongs were done at individual
Collective and systemic levels
I will set out the detail of what
happened and why in my full report
but by judgment is that not only do the
infections themselves and their
consequences Merit compensation
but so too
do the wrongs done by Authority whose
response served to compound people's
suffering
in this report which the media have just
been given in the last couple of hours
to read over and has just been released
the first being that Hepatitis B should
also be recognized the third the second
being that psychological support should
be offered here in England and as it is
across the other parts of the other
nations across the UK psychological
support should be given to those who
have been bereaved and thirdly the fact
that these interim payments should now
be extended to include other family
members toting some 100 000 pounds per
victims